[Music]
English lessons today's mini English
lesson is on solving the mystery of why
it is so difficult to understand English
speakers when they're speaking connected
speech connected speech basically means
that when words are pronounced together
they affect each other and they're
pronounced a little bit differently than
if they were just by themselves today
we're going to look at disappearing
sounds if you look at the sentence I
can't speak Italian it's very clear that
I'm saying the negative can't but listen
to me say it I can't speak Italian the
sound disappears now why is this the
reason that sound disappears is because
when that sound occurs between other
consonant sounds it's actually very
difficult to pronounce
so English speakers just get rid of it
listen I've done it again we just get
rid of it just disappears another sound
is the sound listen to me say the word
friend it's clearly ends with a disk
sound but if I put it in a sentence my
friend gave me this awesome present
yesterday the dip disappears or hold
this carefully it's fragile
it sounds like I'm saying hold not hold
so next time you were listening to an
English speaker speak maybe listen out
for the sounds that they're not making
and that might help decipher what it is
they are saying I hope it helps bye
[Music]